and thank you everybody for for joining
me today um and I just you know before I
start I actually just want to talk a
little bit about um how valuable I I
feel like num focus and the whole P data
Community has been over the last few
years and like building very Community
Centric events in Regional areas and
just like kind of creating an
opportunity for for data scientists and
machine experts kind of get together and
talk about these things and so you know
a big thanks to them for putting on
these events we've been doing them in
Berlin Amsterdam
Seattle um you know it's super excited
to be invited to speak here um and kind
of give all this com every so you know
thanks thanks to p and um
so so this talk is going to be about
building an expert question answer chat
Bo with open source tools now all that's
and to start off I wanted to just kind
of like um talk a little bit about the
kind of the the audience this talk is
geared for us and so we're assuming that
you have experience working python um
and working with some of these
applications um but the Talk itself is
going to is going to go a little bit
deeper into it it assumes an
introductory level um so we're going to
cover some introductory material and
then we have I have code um that we're
going to try to run um to just like
stand up these bots on your own so that
you can see actually how easy it is and
how
a whole wealth of Open Source tools like
Lang chain and gradio and chroma um make
it incredibly easy to actually to stand
up applications with just very very few
lines of code um and that's going to be
like the the the first part of the talk
is kind covering these things and
getting these Basics set up then once we
get past that point we're going to talk
a little bit about how you improve the
performance of these systems um based on
how they're built and so this is we're
going to we're going to pull in tools
like label Studio
um so that you have an opportunity to
give human feedback and how you can
incorporate again these tools into your
annotation platforms and into your
workloads so that you're not just
building Bots that you're sending out
there but you can actually build systems
that give you an opportunity to go back
and interact with them and improve
improve upon their
expence so all of the code is available
as well as the slides and if you head to
this link right here that's going to
take you to the label Studio homepage
where we have a micro page set up for hi
in New York um you'll be able to get the
GitHub repository as well as the slides
and so and this will be available always
so if you want to follow up after grab
these things um us your own stuff like
it's it's available in there for you use
um there is one thing that is a little
bit more difficult um whenever you're
working with
llms there's there's a pretty big
question of like how do you get access
to those and unfortunately free access
is difficult to come by it's hard to
distribute a model because every one of
you is running a different machine that
may or may not be capable of running a
model locally and so if you start using
hosted models it's almost it's very
difficult to find one that doesn't
require you to have some sort of payday
guide um so I want to be completely UPF
front about this that this talk is also
going to require an open an open AI API
key um you know it's it's we we use GPT
3.5 so that like really keep the costs
down um but I want to make you aware of
that because um this is non-free a
non-free service that's being used as
part of the talk um you know and I think
it's something that's difficult to
overcome right now we're making a lot of
progress in open large language models
and other open models um being available
for for Barber consumption but even the
hosting is kind of an issue so what be
transparent on that we
start um and if the this URL is also
written up on the board over here so um
as we move past this slide you should be
able to go there
and start
that okay so what are we going to do uh
we're going to be fine-tuning a QA chat
bot uh to answer questions about label
studio so we're going to be pulling
documentation in from
GitHub using L
chain and
then building and bendings that are
going to go into back
database um using open Ai and then we're
going to use gradio to have a b that is
going to question for us you've probably
seen this before right this is a um very
popular way of doing things but if you
haven't then you know you'll see how
easy it is to kind of get started with
this let's start off with an
introduction to large language
models if you if you if you have don't
have a lot of experience with ls it's
like you know you may be wondering like
you hear this word a lot what does it
mean and you can almost llm stands for
large language model and you can think
of it as you know there's a library
analogy that goes along with this where
you can consider the internet to be a
giant library of knowledge and llms are
like a library a librarian that has read
every single book of the
library um you can ask the library
anything and you'll get a response based
off of what they've
read now the answers may not always be
perfect
um but typically they're impressive and
one of the goals that we want is that we
want to address this idea that they're
not perfect because because we know that
there's so much knowledge out there and
that some things may be good some things
may be bad and one of the best ways to
identify things that aren't great is to
bring human knowledge
into so llms are trained by kind of this
approach of like guess the next word um
imagine you're teaching someone to speak
and you read a sentence to them and they
just have to predict the next word and
then based off of that prediction you
give them
feedback um and they make Corrections on
that over time they would begin to
recognize the patterns and notice the
similarities and you can think of lolm
as having read billions of sentences um
predicting character as well as Words
which is important for coding um and
it's using this to learn deep
patterns and you might ask well how do
the questions work
well LMS have billions of parameters and
so these models are huge I mean I think
they're I've read billions to trillions
on some of these models they're they're
absolutely um and a parameter is just
like if you imagine it's a giant
mathematical function every one of these
parameters is just like thinking of like
a like if you have a polinomial where
you have you know a s plus you know ax2
plus BX plus C right those a and C's are
parameters but imagine that there are
trillions billions of these
and you're tuning these you're just like
you're making small corrections to those
you're giving input checking the
output um so with each guess you compare
the answers the LOL gave to the answer
that you wanted and you treat that
difference like a compass that points in
the direction you want to tune the
parameters in um it's a method typically
we call it grading a descent and there
are a bunch of different ways that you
can that you can do it but you know
another way to think about it is like
you're blindfolded and you are trying to
navigate some terrain you want to find
your way to the bottom of a mountain and
you just always take small steps in the
directions that take you down the hill
right there another way to think about
how this
works model is adjusted and the next
step is taken and slowly this landscape
of the model takes shape right this is
all to just give you a bit of context to
like how these things
work um so LMS are they're winding up
being like massively like two years ago
we barely even thought about these
things right you know there was some
talk of like you know some gbt models
and things that they could do but um
they've really taken it off this year
and and you know you may have like used
you know like Chad gbt for any of these
things like writing a resume for
yourself right like oh help me write a
cover letter for a job that I'm applying
for or you know I need to have some
report finished or you know just asking
questions about General things and so
there's just a massive number of things
that you can do I people even have buil
games on top of
that but the problem is is that this
knowledge is general and domain specific
topics may be
misrepresented llms also just don't
truly understand like they're kind of
like these these General prediction
inin there's a level of inconsistency
you maybe get different answers each
time and most importantly the knowledge
may be out of date depending upon the
data set it was trained on uh um
so you know so for example like some of
the GPT models like their knowledge
ended September
2021 you know which means that anything
that's happened from that point forward
like you know about applications you may
be using or world events um may not be
true like and like a perfect example of
this is try asking in L what the weather
is going to be today right it just
doesn't know because it hasn't been pred
on historic
data
um there are ways around those problems
but um you know but this is you know
generally speaking like the knowledge
base that this train on is is is usually
fixed at a certain point in
time okay with all this in place we're
going to um start thinking about how can
we build a QA system right so we have an
llm and the first thing that we want to
do is just build a system that can
answer
questions so our goal is we're going to
build a chat bot and in this case um
we're going to build a chat bot that can
answer questions about label Studio
label studio is an open source data
labeling platform that that company I
work for makes um but really in this
Workshop I encourage you if you want to
build a chat bot that answers questions
about something else like you can go to
any GitHub repository with markdown
documentation and tailor the bot for
your own
purposes
um so we're we're going to be asking
chat gbt about label Studio but has
happened since 2021 we've had two years
of development since since this was uh
since this was built um so we're going
to grab the documentation from GitHub
we're going to help help build some
context for the
chatot
um and you know and help train up the
model
this but how are we going to do this
well there are a ton of different ways
that you can
actually train retrain llms like the
most expensive way is to go in and
actually do fine tuning against the
model itself where you are going in and
changing the parameters it's incredibly
expensive um and and difficult it takes
a lot of resources um and it's quite
frequently just not available to
everyone but there are all sorts of
techniques that we can use to actually
leverage the strengths of large language
models that don't require us to go in
and completely retrain the whole thing
um in the example that we're going to be
giving today we're going to use a
technique called retrieval augmented
generation and
the idea behind this is is that we're
going to collect our data set so in this
case the label Studio
documentation and then we're going to
build what we call a vector database
from that data
set um the database is going to consist
of a mapping between our input strings
which are coming from the documentation
and output vectors which represent some
sort of semantic information about
what's in that
document and then we're going to insert
these vectors and text into the doc
database and if you don't understand all
of these terms we're going to get into
what these mean in in the next
slides um then when we ask the chat bot
a question we're going to convert the
question into one of these embeddings
and so we're also going to compute a
semantic Vector based off of this we're
going to select the top documents that
are similar to our question based off of
the context and then we're going to
query open AI with the open AI model
with context from the docs and the user
and then we're going to return you the
response and so we're going to in some
ways precede the the the chapel with
information that's related to the
question that we're answering so that I
can evaluate that also and generate an
appropriate
response and in this way we're kind of
like transferring more current knowledge
into the large language models sh
text you may have heard me you know use
that word embedding in vectors um and
what is an embedding exactly like how
many how many people like kind of work
with embedding and understand how they
work and they do so so some to some
folks so if you hear the word embedding
you know essentially what you are trying
to do with it is you're turning lumpy
things into the real world especially
like words are really
lumpy um into continuous
variables um because large language
models like we're using these large
mathematical functions and they're
performing operations doing continuous
mathematics against non-continuous
things
so you can take an iive mapping um of
different categories of of categories of
vectors numbers and you can lose meaning
so like one way that that that you can
do an embedding is what's called Hot
Shot embedding where you just assign a
number to a word right and so maybe the
word cat gets the number one and maybe
the word chair gets the number two and
you just you build up a large mapping of
of words to numbers and then you can
have your vectors represent that but as
you can tell like
you know cat and chair may not have any
like there may be no um you know no
relation between the two and you can try
to do more complicated things or you're
trying to group things naturally but it
takes a ton of work and it it's not
necessarily going to produce the best
results it's a fast way to do it but it
can it it can cause you some
problems um so you're better off trying
to build some sort of complex mapping
that tries to capture semantic meaning
from this and and um you know and you
know you know in some sense like you
know creates creates a vector where
vectors that are close to one another
you know for the words could have
similar meaning and it helps answer
questions like is a teapot like a dog or
is a dog like a hot dog or is a hot dog
a sandwich you can imagine that all of
these different words in these contexts
there's a distance between them like the
distance between teapot and dog is very
large
the distance between dog and a hot dog
is
smaller and the distance between a hot
dog and sandwich is probably going to be
the smallest of the
three and so what we're doing is that
we're measuring similarities um a good
edding converts the input into a numeric
Vector of fixed length that captures
semantic meaning and vectors that are
close to one another carry similar
meaning um and there are many metrics
that are available and like one of the
ways that you can do this is that you
actually train a machine learning model
against a large data set of words and
then you don't care about what the
outputs are you use the um the weights
that are generated in the inner layer
when you when you input as you're
embedding and it's that way you capture
the semantic similarity and so when we
talk about embeddings this is what we're
talking about and when you go to API
when you go to services like open a AI
they're actually going to give you apis
where you can hand it strings of words
and it'll hand back an embeding to you
and so you know that's that's how we're
going to build our our embeding Mees um
the drawback of this is um you look at
these embeddings and it's there's just
like looking at it as a human you lose
all of the context and so there are
trade-offs for these things but um this
is why they being a very powerful
solution for for helping us translate um
real world language into
things that machines have a better can
do a better job of processing
understanding so what we're going to do
is we're going to take these embeddings
we're going to use fixed Vector to
represent the text documents use our LMS
to compute the embeddings and then we're
going to put them into a vector database
which Maps the text that we have to the
embeding vectors and then we can do
queries against this um and particularly
what we're going to do is what when we
ask a question we're going to create
embedding out of that and then we're
going to go to the vector database and
ask for all of the text that M that
closely matches the question that we
answer that we ask right does that make
sense does that does that did that help
clear
up makes sense just okay
yeah okay
so
um so the way that we're going to like
do some of these things is we're going
to leverage open source libraries that
are that exist right now and you know
that that are kind of out there and the
first one that we're going to Le heavily
against is Lang chain which is an entire
tool set that is meant to help you build
language applications against large
language models um you know they provide
a bunch of different tools for you for
you to be able to do
this and so on our code what we're going
to do is we're going to use this concept
of document loaders where Lang chain
provides a number of different API for
you to to to ingest documents we're
going to use it git
loader we're going to give it a path
that we're going to save the documents
too so we're going to save the the
documents locally we'll clone the
repository and then we will um load all
of the
data with every file that has a path
that matches empty so we're going to go
in work out files um so if you're using
like rst as your documentation format
you would just replace the with rst if
you're using text files um if you want
to pull the documents from somewhere
else like maybe you want to pull from
Wikipedia or something like there
document loaders that will go and grab
documents from different sources um but
we're going to be using the git loader
we're going to be pulling in marked out
files because we document label Studio
Mar then we're going the data into
that and then from there we're going to
use LINE chain to process the data um
now one of the things that we need to
remember too is that large language
models typically have context context
windows and they have a maximum length
of data that you can put into them um so
we're going to try to chunk the data up
so that we only worry about 500
character
blocks um we're going to use open AI
embeddings to provide all of our um
embedding vectors um the nice thing is
is like again using libraries like Lang
chain means that if we want to swap out
to different inventing models we want to
swap out to different large language
models we can do that if we want and we
can even use embedding models that are
different from the L that we want to use
right because you know there's there's
not a tight um you know there's you know
because because we're looking for
semantic similarity with the embeddings
and then we're going to use the llm to
generate text based off of that and so
you could actually use entirely
differents if you want you can kind of
mix and match these
things um and we're going to use chroma
as our Vector database and by using
chroma it just means that we don't have
to worry about doing computations that
like Computing similarity we'll be able
to do search as faster so using other
tools to kind of do all the heavy
lifting for us and so we're going to
take this uh we're going to split up our
markdown text you split the documents up
and we're just going to load them
directly into the vector store uh with
the embeddings that we
specified so with that actually we can
kind of go into the uh the workshop part
of this with kind of all of this
background
information um and uh and begin working
on
this so let's let's uh let's start
by by building our bot
so let me
see so we can start this by going
to
um to this repository this label Studio
examples this is linked in the um from
the from the from the site that we have
here and we are going to
um download this
repository and we're going to go into
this question answering
system directory so this is the
directory we're going to be working
on you can see there are number of
different
um a number of
different um python files that we can
look at and there's also a read to help
you get started now um we're not going
to get to the point where we need label
Studio quite yet that's going to be
further in at the end of the talk but I
want to give everyone a little bit of a
warning that that probably going to be
the most time intensive part of this of
this Workshop getting that installed um
just because it's it depending upon if
you're running Linux or Mac or Windows
the installation process may be a little
bit different um really if you're going
to be using label Studio you know if
you're following along I would suggest
one of the easiest ways is if you have a
hugging face account go to hugging face
spaces and replicate the label Studio
space there and use that it will
probably be the fastest way to install
it but you if you're on Mac I suggest
using
homeb um or Docker um if you're on Abu
or
Linux you're probably fine here um so I
am going to actually remove this first
line from requirements. text because I'm
going to run label studio and docker
um I'm also going to run this inside of
a virtual environment um if if you're
familiar with python development I like
to install things in Virtual
environments or something similar
because I don't know what something's
going to install and I like to keep my
my working environment as clean as
possible when I'm trying to things out
um so running this virtual environment
creating that means that we're going to
be um we make mistakes or something get
install that we don't like it's easy to
uninstall
right
um and we're just going all these
requirements
oh right live coding here
too and as you're as fing as you're
working on this if you have questions
feel free to ask if you're run into
troubles
um uh Havey to work through
this
which one did you remove from the
requirements the label Studio One
yeah and we can we can install it later
if we
want okay so with that
installed um the first document that I
want us to look at is this
um
uh build doc
DB and so this is the code that we were
looking at
before we're going to be um we're going
to be using Lane chain with the git
loader mark down text
splitter open Ai embeddings and Chrome
for all of this
um we're
we're this is going to take the longest
amount of time um you're Ling the
repository that you're interested in
label studio is a pretty big repository
so it it'll take a while to to to
download it split up the documents
compute the embeddings and load them
into chroma this is provided as a this
is wrapped up in main so you can provide
your own repo path if you want to your
own
URLs um and uh um and you'll be able to
look from
that so so if we run this
using we start with the help we can just
look at this and
see see how that works and so we'll just
build that using the defaults
here but you can use your own values if
you
want um this is the part that's going to
take a little take a little while the
source for this is if you go to this URL
it label Studio where the
doio slpy DAT
NYC yeah so so when home on the Mac it's
a package manager um you need to get
application
specific packaging for it so that group
tap command does that Brew
install human signals slash tab SL label
Studio we'll install it and then you'll
be able to run it if you have Docker
running
um
and if you search for label install
label Studio like there page here that
that that covers this um but the key
here is that you want to do the stalker
run um you want to you want to make you
want to open up Port 880 because that's
where the application is going to be
hosted um mounting this volume I think
is actually for this for this event
could could be optional um but then you
just use hardex Labs label Studio latest
um and that will get the latest version
of label studio and then I'll have it
running on for 8 um if you also go to
um hugging face yeah and creating their
spaces you can also use this we have a
label Studio template to get you started
this is entirely free we'll give you the
right version super best I think yeah
and this and this will this will work
fine for us
too okay so let's go back here this is
still slow I probably should have
preloaded this data before before I did
this um this is why sometimes it might
be nicer to to use it but we've vaded
the data um now we're going to compute
our Bings and and input it into the
database um so this will take a little
little bit uh oh the other thing that we
need to do also is uh you're going to
see that I'm going to run into an error
here and it's because I didn't set my
open API key right I need my open API
key to be able to compute the
embeddings
um so I won't show the open API key but
you want to export this as an
environment variable
um
uh you can kind of actually see a little
bit there I guess I will show my opinion
AI key um I'll cancel it at the end of
the talk um that's the environment
variable you want to
use and then if I rerun this again this
build doc um it's not going to download
we we cache the repository so it's not
going to go and uh try to download it
again um but now it's going to go out
and it's going to start communicating
with open open AI to compute all bar
embeddings and bring those into the
database and so that's our first step
here
how's everyone going on this step is
anyone running any problems or you all
able to follow
along okay dep res yeah yeah yeah yeah
and I would I if you're if you're
running into the problem with with if
you're running into dependency
resolution problems I would delete label
Studio from that line and requirements.
text and install without because we can
we can use other things to get there
okay so if we look at this directory too
um while you're working on this I
actually think it's instructive to just
start up a simple chat
bot that doesn't
do anything like you know any of the
training that we do there and and and I
like this because it actually shows you
how easy it is to actually start on a
chat bot um you import a few libraries
and so you bring in Lane chain um with
the chat open AI
model um you you wrap it up in gradio so
you build a gradio application out of
this um and you essentially just you
know create a prediction function which
is like you know takes the input from
your chat and then Returns the output um
and then you have a chat interface this
is just this C is essentially copy and
pasted from the gradio getting starting
guides um but it's the start for all
this and so we take a look at
it
um we can run this
application give it a chance to start
up which file do you call the the open
API key because I have to the file so I
want to read it from the file yeah I
usually set it as an environment
variable and then I understand but in
which file um which python file in your
repository use oh I don't I don't I
don't I just I just created a file and I
have uh an ex I just um I'll show you
here um in my home directory I have an
open API key file I no sorry so my
question is regarding because I have my
open AP start in the file I don't want
to start environment for whatever
reason which file in the repository the
workshop Repository will we use the open
API key so I can write this yeah all of
them all of them use it yeah yeah all of
them use
it um yeah so if we so if we start this
app up um so this is running locally
this is a gradio app and um you know
what sort of what sort of question do we
want to ask you we can ask we could ask
anything like you
know how do I install label
Studio
you know and it's and it actually you
know it takes a little bit it's going to
go out get an answer and come back um
and it actually has a pretty good it
gives a pretty good answer um it tells
you that this is correct um it tells you
you need python 3.6 that actually is a
pretty good indication of how old this
is I don't think python 36 is even
supported anymore um support yeah so um
so you can tell like the age of the
answer there um but you know for the
most part it's actually it's not a bad
answer so we can exit this application
and then we can look at what I'm calling
my Advanced
chatbot um this is where we add
information about the embeddings into it
and so you can see that we're pulling in
our our Vector store
um we build this QA chain and so again
like this is nice because Lang chain has
actually built up a lot of this for us
so we don't have to do a lot of the work
um we give it a model name
um uh we give it the predict function um
you know and you know you know what
essentially we're using the uh
um you know the additional information
from the per database to be able to to
load a bit of context into the model
um right and so you have the you know
you're you're you're getting the
retriever there so you're you know
getting you know that's how you're kind
feeding that context information into
that and so if we run this advaned chat
bot and we'll give it a little bit of
time to war
up
um asking the same
question it actually changes quite a bit
um you know and I think we might have
changed the L model that we were using
too um but you know it actually gives
you a shorter answer um which may or may
not be better
um but this is based on the context and
you so you can see but but it's not
giving us that bad information anymore
um let's see if it if it
understands um so now it understands you
python version 3.8 or better right so
this information is already more up to
date and this is based off the documents
that we and so this at at the most basic
level is just like you can do this for
any application that you want and indeed
I have seen tons of organizations that
are starting to use this as ways to
augment their U their support systems um
we use it internally at human signal for
like you know to kind of like help
spread the load of like helping our
customers like we have like a highly
tuned chat bot that we go to and
sometimes people will go and ask the
questions about that and then they'll
you know you know like you know if we
have someone who you know isn't as much
of an expert you know but they still
want to help out one of you know you
know user or customer to be able to do
that and so this is becoming really
popular um you know you kind of see how
simple it is like to get started you
know using this how powerful these tools
are becoming like you know two years ago
it would have been a completely
different story building something like
this you know I think it's I think it's
this is like some you know pretty
exciting okay um yeah so the slides just
have some uh some some uh you know some
do some docks on this and
um
uh you know getting the
repository running the simple chat bot
make sure you export your open API
key
um we have these commands here we built
our doc database we ran Advanced
chapot um but now we want I want I want
to bring this to the next part of the
talk which is um this is nice but you
know there 's always room for
improvement and one of the things that I
strongly believe in is that although
llms are incredible at doing all sorts
of automated things they still only get
better when we provide them with some
sort of human feedback and we give them
some sort of feedback but one of the
reasons that chat GPT has been so great
was because they took these original
gpt3 models and they started doing a lot
of reinforcement learning from Human
feedback on that and so actually having
a ton of people look at the outputs and
rank the answers and then using that to
go back and build a model that could
fine-tune and you know kind of build
these safer more informative models um
and this is I think this is always going
to be the case that if you are looking
for a competitive advantage in this
advantage in this
space the better you can embed expert
knowledge and have that knowledge be um
evaluated you know against like expert
knowledge um the better off you're going
to
be um because you know because we keep
lowering the bar of how easy it is to
use these models and the the main
differentiator is going to be how much
human knowledge and feedback you can put
into
those okay so as we were kind of like
you know looking at before like we saw
like you know some answers were maybe
good some answers were bad some answers
could be improved upon um and we want to
incorporate this human
expertise okay so you can consider all
the different way ways to do this we
talked about this a little bit earlier
like an easy way to do this is actually
to add good responses to the vector DB
this is actually the what we're going to
be covering for the rest of
today
um medium difficulty um which will be an
exercise for you to kind of do on your
own but you should be able to do at the
end of this talk if you can look through
the examples is to curate additional
documents to improve the bad
responses and then the hard is like
fine-tuning the llm where you collect a
lot of data you retrain it's a complex
proc process an it's an expensive
process this is well beyond the scope of
this
talk okay so how are we going to do
this um well we're going to have our
chat bot and every time that we ask it a
question we actually want to capture the
input and we want to capture the output
so that we can evaluate it in some
way and the evaluation tool that we're
going to use is label Studio because it
provides a natural way for you to build
a number of if you're if you're not
familiar with the label studio is it's
it's an open source data labeling
platform that lets you kind of pull in
almost any sort of data that you want
create um targeted annotation interfaces
towards those and so if you're bringing
in images you can have like object
detection in the images um you can pull
in text and have sentiment analysis you
can pull in video and have frame
detection um and you have it and you can
mix human input so and haters who are
going in and like you know saying that
like this sentence is you know this
person is being mean this person is
being kind if you're stive analysis or
saying like this is a picture of a dog
this is a picture of a cat if you're
doing some sort of object object
identification in this case what we're
going to be doing is we're going to be
bringing in the questions and the
responses and having annotators label
the responses either as good or bad
right and and then we're going to be
using that to um you know bring in the
good responses to kind of like reinforce
the uh the sort of embeddings that we're
getting back out from our from our chat
bot this is going to be done by using
linkchain callbacks and so label Studio
has um is integrated with linkchain as
one of one of their callback mechanisms
and so link chain link chain will
actually handle the Gathering all the
information and then then sending the
call to label studio and creating a new
task for your annotation team inside of
label Studio and then you'll be ready to
live
it and so in this way we're going to be
able to improve the system we create a
feedback loop where users are constantly
using the system and then annotators are
constantly evaluating the the output
from that and improving upon those
responses um we can also use more
advanced feachers to kind of like
understand the metrics and so often
times annotators can disagree
right that's one of the that's one of
the good things about human feedback is
you actually get you can have multiple
people look at it you can you can you
can give scores you can uh you know
maybe annotators disagree and you can
use that as a means to to further
evaluate the effectiveness of the
answers um but what we're going to do in
this process is we're going to we're
going to send responses to label Studio
we're going to do The annotation we're
going to export that
data and then run a that will
incorporate those responses into
building into our embeddings database
and then we're going to restart that up
and that will that's the process that
we're going to use to improve the chat
bot in a production system this would
actually you would want to automate
these things and kind of help build this
interior ml pipeline but this is just
kind of an example to like give you a
taste of how something like this would
look okay so uh so let's build a better
bot okay we're going to start off by by
launching lat
studio
um so um depending upon how you have it
installed um there are a bunch of
different ways that you can do this
uh I am going to run it through Docker
um I have this I have this running
on um on Docker here you know where I'm
going to do Docker run have them
listening at Port 880 um running the
latest latest version of label
studio so we have this running here I'm
actually just going to create a new
project um I'm going to call
this YC
three okay so label student has the
concepts of projects and in a project
you are annotating a particular type of
data set that you're that you're
interested in and when you first launch
label Studio it's going to ask you to
create a login um
uh
um if you you know and then when you
create your first project it's going to
give you a bunch of different options
and so you can see like we have computer
vision natural language processing
conversational AI ranking and scoring
we're just going to create a custom
template for this um just so that we can
walk through exactly how this works and
kind of give you a feeling of like how
you build these labeling
interfaces it's all done through
XML um which we have a um kind of like a
like a just a bunch of different tags
that you can use to build the interface
out um if we head back
to the repository here
um we have the interface that we want to
use right here here so this is the
labeling
configuration we can just run through
this really quick
to to kind of you know talk about what
what each of these means um you can you
can embed styling inside of it so you
can make it look nice we have a bunch of
styles Here style here this is just
standard CSS which goes into this um we
have views which are which are kind of
like dibs in uh in HTML if you're
familiar with with HTML um
you give it a chat container and so it's
going to be able to like um you know
essentially give you a double
interface you have different variables
that are in here and so for example um
within your labeling data set you're
going to have a column named prompt so
every Row in your data set is going to
have some value in that PRP and that's
what's going to be displayed to your
annotation team um then there's going to
be a response and so that's the response
of the that the chat bot gave back to it
um this is also going to be a
value
that's just kind of like in your you
know and if you imagine like if you're
doing like financial data like you know
maybe you're looking at transactions and
so you might have like a transaction ID
you know like the value with um you know
with you know with who it was at or if
you're if you're doing images like you
know there may be like an image label
that points to URL for an image that
you're labeling so it's a super flexible
interface that lets you kind of like
display a bunch of different things
inside of
it um but then we come down to here and
we have we we can give uh instructions
so like this is ask you tell asking the
annotator to rate the answer um but then
we have this this down here which is
choices right and this is one of the
input
um uh one of the
uh um input parameters that you can give
to your labeling interface where your
Entertainer actually gets to choose is
this good or bad right and again it's
highly configurable like you could have
neutral you could have a p of no
um you know you know and this will and
this will be written to
um to the to the to the field uh to the
name rating right you know which is
which is going to you know which is
which is going to appear as one of the
columns in our in our in our annotation
interface um and you can see a preview
of what that looks like and so you can
see that we have our our prompt up here
our response down here and then The
annotation interface there and so we're
going to save this project
we don't have any data yet that's what
we're going to be doing with uh with our
latest chat bot but the first thing I
need to do is
actually um I need to get an API key for
label studio and I also need to know the
URL that I'm doing that that I'm
connecting to if you're running on
hugging face you're going to have you're
going to have to look up the URL um make
sure that your space is public to be
able to to access it um if you're
running a locally Local Host is just
going to work fine in this
instance um but I'm going to copy this
and then if we uh come back to our
example here we want to export our label
Studio API
key okay so let's let's close our chat
off
here okay so we have so we have that
loaded indor environment and then let's
look at this uh chat bot file and so
this was the the original chat bot that
did this that they ship with um you'll
notice it's very similar to what we had
before um we have our Vector store we
have so we're going to be retrieving
this from um but we also the thing that
we want to note here is that we have
this label studio
callac and so this is going to read our
API key from the from from the
environment um look at the URL and then
every time linkchain sees a response
come in it's going to call it's going to
make a call this to this call back
Handler and it's going to write a new
task into into label studio for our
annotators to look at um and then pretty
much everything else is just the same um
again this is 60 lines of code right and
a good chunk of those are just import
statements so if we run this version of
our chat bot um ah so so this was
something too that we need to there
actually more parameters that
um that we need to set when we run this
um so we already have our label Studio
API key as an environment variable but
we actually need to give it a URL that
we want to look at we want it to go to
so it will Studio URL in this case
is Local
Host um we need to give it a project ID
because it needs to know which project
it has to write into um you can actually
get this
by um we go back to our projects
here
um the easiest way to do this is
actually to look at the URL up here you
can see that there's a 16 up there which
is the project ID um we are actually
working on improving the API to service
that a little bit faster to also give a
project I by name be able to look that
up um it's an improvement that's coming
in
um and our
persistent directory this is in a this
is where we essentially saved our our
our database our Ving
database um so now we have we have new
chat B
running um and if we come back here to
our where's our chat
window
um okay so we can ask how do I install
studio right we restarted our bot we're
going to ask a
question
um we're going to get this question here
this one actually you know came back and
said that we make sure you have label
Studio 3. installed before we do that
then if we come back to our project and
we hit reload we're going to see that a
new task has been loaded in there with
uh
with with the response that we have and
so we
have we have the um
we have the prompt we have the response
um and we can rate it as good or bad and
we I don't we'll say this is good right
you know it didn't tell me anything
wrong you know maybe it wasn't as
complete as we wanted um but you know
this can be this can be a good answer
but you know maybe you know
um right we can ask a question how do I
install hooking
face it actually doesn't know right and
um so um we can mark this one
as um if we go back to ear interface we
can actually maybe Mark the answer to
this one as B we can see that
there
um there's something little fun is
happening the
database uh on that my demos are always
kind of this way um
um but yeah so you know so so so we're
going through and and and while we're
working with the chat Boog we're able to
do this and this you know this means
that you can actually have this thing
running live you can be exposing it to
your users they can be working on it and
your annotation team can be working in
the background like saying like yeah
this was good this was bad and and you
know and kind of going through and um
making these
changes now when we're ready like when
we feel like the anotation team has done
their you know is like done a good job
and we're ready to like like start
bringing this information back
in what we want to do is take what we
consider the good answers and actually
start bringing these back into our
edting database so that we have text
that we know this contextually is you
know has like good context has a good
answer um and that we want to be able to
help guide the responses from the chat B
even
more so you can export your data here
export this as as a can export this as a
Json
file um
and we can actually
uh look at
this so we have project 16 which
is the data that we output here and you
can just see that it's it's just you
know Json file with like all of the data
that we have there um so it's structured
nicely which means that you can kind of
bring this in and introduce it to the
rest of your
pipeline and so the call that we're
going to use to do this is this add
documents
command um
where we're going to parse the the data
from that from that Json file we're
going to pick everything that's good and
we're just going to load that into into
our chroma
database
so we're going to go into our Vector
store we're going to get our good
examples extract those and then add them
add those to our dogs right and this
should give you a clue actually as to
how you can improve this right so you
know a way that you should be able to
improve um you know how your annotations
are even happening because if you think
about it like just saying that something
is good or bad it's just like a very
basic level of feedback that we're
giving to the system an ideal level of
feedback would be for someone to correct
the box for the bad answers right and
say that no what you should have
answered this
way
um and we'll leave that as kind of an
exercise to the user you should be able
to kind of see how you might want to be
able to build something um you know that
that adds these things into here um so
if we do Python 3 add
documents so we just want to make sure
that we
have don't I'm not
in
okay so I just need to give it
a
Json project 16 um
this goes through and adds the documents
um and then we can restart our our QA
bot now this is one of the questions too
is like without a lot of data it's
actually hard to evaluate like is this
helping or is this is this not helping
um but when we shut this down and we
start it back up we're going to start
the the units back up with the with that
one new embeding that we've added about
you know whether the answer was was good
um for for installing label
Studio okay so incorporating human
feedback is going to be a part of all
syu yes you had a question good question
um when my for example uh the API
returned I don't have the answer for
this um was that just opener eyes
summarizing the results from the or is
just some kind of processing from like
Ling the middle yeah
so I I don't know actually like I know
that like so so so what's happening
behind the scenes is
um Lang chain is going to the chroma
database and
collecting of like whatever the top like
10 documents or whatever it is that it
feels like provide the most context and
then they're feeding that into the
context window for for open Ai and I
think
that I think that when you provide a
context window know that open actually
tries to use
it um and um but I'm you know so and if
it and if it doesn't have I've seen this
before where where it actually says that
you haven't provided enough context for
me to answer this question um so I think
that's actually you know know it that
that's happening on the API side and you
know if you just ask opening eye
directly about it I don't know if it
would give you a answer I mean we we
could we could actually run
the the simple one and actually find out
if we you
know if we wanted
to I me the sorry of the uh the one that
you show on the screen where yeah but I
think yeah I think I think that has to
do with the context M fed into open open
AI like I think that's what part of what
caused it to say that
information yeah um so you know these
are very general tools like you
know not that much code you got a lot of
power into it but this is a way that you
can start
introducing
um you know callbacks and annotation
into you know kind of into
you to uh really in into into a you know
into a better workflow you know so the
challenge is that I kind of actually you
know think that if you work through the
examples and you start and you start
going through this we have about I don't
know uh 20 minutes left or so um for
this for this talk is like how can you
build a bot with better feedback right
how can we incorporate better human
feedback into the
system so you know like kind of the key
hints are here is that you would need to
update your label configuration to
incorporate human feedback into the bad
answers right
um and then you would need to modify
your processing script to write the
feedback into the vector database and so
recall that when we were giving you know
we Mark something is good we just took
the responses and we just wrote that
back out this context for the database
um you know but but taking these fields
and then say okay is the answer bad you
know what is the feedback on this and
then take Tak that as the context to be
able to do it that way you're not just
taking the feedback for the good answers
but you're taking the feedback for the
bad
answers um and you could you know so
like for example on on a on the label
Studio side of
things um that might
[Music]
mean um going into your settings and
going into your labeling
interface
um and we have a whole uh
whole list of like apis for you to be
able
to um you know kind of add new tags into
into these things but like you know
maybe we wanted to add say a uh I think
there's a text label
tag
um Point lab labels anyway yeah we can
uh
you would want to find your your text
label tag to be able to add into the
interface yeah right there you would
have a
uh oh that's actually the text I would
have
to actually a clue could be
to we go to the
general I don't want to dig too deeply
into this time
have um yeah that kind of bring you to
the end of the workshop to the end of
the
[Applause]
talk